halten sie das szenario für
wahrscheinlich oder das millionen
deutsche leben herr faßbender im herbst
sagen werden in der abwägung ist eben
mir die wohnung die warme wohnung ist
mir das gas aus russland lieber als die
sanktionen die treffen uns mittlerweile
härter als putin ja ich versuche mal so
sein ihre kausalität ist ja absolut
nachvollziehbar auf eine gewisse ihre
auf eine gewisse weise hat dass beides
nicht miteinander zu tun aber schauen
was dort hat die reale situation an wenn
jetzt im nächsten monat in den nächsten
acht wochen keine erfolgreiche
ukrainische gegenoffensive geschieht wir
können davon ausgehen dass ich gehe
davon aus dass die russischen das
russische vordringen mehr oder weniger
in dem in dem jetzigen rahmen bleibt
wenn sich das ganze also fest frist ja
und dann kommen die probleme die
ökonomischen probleme vonstatten
zimmermann hat ihre fraktion in drei
vier fünf monaten und viel viel
schwierigeren stand weil dann nämlich
die menschen sagen das eine hat mit dem
anderen vielleicht nichts zu tun aber
warum werfen wieder weiter im monat für
monat woche für woche in einen krieg in
dem sich nichts bewegt wo es doch
zumindest die hoffnung gebe wenn es
diesen krieg nicht gäbe ging es uns
unsere borgmann de besser das muss man
den menschen eben erklären deswegen kann
man ja nicht seine politik weinberger
nur sie können es erwarten sie neigen
werfen also zu machen sie werfen
hineingeworfen sondern wir haben eine
diskussion geführt was geliefert wird
was nicht der bundeskanzler hat gb 7 und
jetzt bei dem nato ganz klar zum
ausdruck gebracht und wir begrüßen das
ausdrücklich
er sagte wir werden der ukraine so lange
waffen liefern wie die ukraine ist
benötigt wir diskutieren jetzt über die
art der waffen das kann man alles machen
aber eher distanziert sich eben nicht
davon im gegenteil es war der
bundeskanzler dass jahre dauert glauben
sie dabei schauen sie mal wir machen
politik aus dem jetzt heraus wir werden
das wieder was wir diskutieren in paar
jahren wird über uns gerichtet werden
und das meine ich mit großem respekt war
das richtig was die bundesrepublik
gemacht hat war das was die
bundesregierung gemacht hat es gibt
keine bundesregierung in diesem land die
nach 80 tagen mit einer solchen
situation konfrontiert wurde in der tat
und deswegen entscheiden wir heute
diskutieren wegen ab entscheiden ob das
am langen ende richtig ist dass werden
die entscheiden geschichtsbücher mal
befüllen damit unsere enkel nerven dass
versprechen lassen man ist ja auch immer
sprechen der ukraine so lange bis sie
heilen das braucht teil ist ausdrücklich
was der bundeskanzler sagt weil es eben
um sehr viel geht und deswegen muss man
das den menschen erklären und ich bin
bayern müller in diesen fällen müssen
wir in der lage sein denen wo eben jeder
100 euro schein an ausgaben mehr für
energie denen müssen wir helfen das
heißt aber nicht dass jedem in
deutschland das schmerzt aber denen wo
es an die substanz geht muss geholfen
werden
und ich bin auch optimistisch genug dass
wir das auch hinbekommen bei dir ja
bereits seit wochen uns alternativen
anschauen und es ist ja ganz spannend
wenn ich das nicht bin überhaupt keine
energiepolitikerin deswegen bitte kein
weiteres gespräch darüber was wage ich
aus dem fenster zu lehnen die tatsache
dass wir uns mit gefragten gas
beschäftigen die tatsache dass plötzlich
genehmigungen um diese zu speichern sehr
sehr schnell gehen in wenigen monaten wo
einer sagt also wenn wir das machen das
dauert jahre das zeigt ja dass unter
diesem druck unter dem wir stehen
nämlich dass die bevölkerung nicht
friert unglaublich viel möglich ist das
was wir uns vor einem jahr die übrigens
ihr vieles nicht haben wird man das über
mit geld zu schmieren können verzeihen
sie den begriff aber wenn der kanzler
von sozialem sprengstoff spricht und sie
diejenigen ansprechen die brutal unter
den strom- und gasrechnungen leiden
werden im herbst und im winter meistens
diejenigen die arbeiten gehen die nicht
so viel geld verdienen die meisten die
eine familie haben also ein bisschen
größere wohnung haben die werden
darunter leiden glauben sie dass man das
diesen herbst und winter mit geld zu
schmieren kann ich denke ja es ist ja
für viele leute ein finanzielles problem
und finanzielle probleme kann man lösen
indem man denjenigen menschen die
wirklich tochter leighton
erleichterung finanzielle erleichterung
gibt meinte ich brauche das nicht ich
komme allein darüber aber es gibt viele
leute und ich glaube dass die mehrzahl
der normalen leute die haben probleme
und haben was man sehen wie man etwa
durch steuersenkungen oder durch
zuschüsse dem menschen hilft über diesen
winter zu kommen da dieser winter wird
das schwierigste sein danach wird es
besser werden also nahe diese
bundesregierung und die vorgängig auch
bei köhler sehr viel geld
und nachsehen noch mit corona das wäre
also alles zusammen ja aber rein
psychologisch gehen wir heute anders
damit um wurden wurde auch vielen
geholfen neben persönlichen schicksalen
keine frage branche besonders betroffen
waren auch verwerfungen die wir heute
spüren weil viele ihrem beruf geändert
haben trotzdem haben wir im vergleich zu
internationalen ausland ein letztlich
unglaublich viel hinbekommen und
deswegen würde ich nicht sagen das
erinnert mich so ein bisschen an nicht
glücklich zu mit meiner kohle so ist
zwar noch ein bisschen anders dieses
zitat ja das war ich erstmal noch so ich
weiß jetzt der alten gelungen ist also
auf alle fälle das natürlich hilft wenn
man menschen
wenn man sie finanziell entlastet ja
natürlich weil es ein finanzielles
problem ist und dann wird in deutschland
nicht das passieren was manche
befürchten dass es dann heißt der
faßbender germany first
alles mögliche schlimme kann passieren
ich möchte einfach mal den ich möchte
mal das augenmerk noch mal eine ganz
andere sichtweise und also ich soll mal
kurz bei dem gedanken bleiben weil es
gibt diesen gedanken längst er wird von
ihren kollegen im bundestag kollegen in
anführungsstrichen von der afg längst
ausgesprochen es gibt stimmen lassen sie
uns das einmal reichen ein video das in
dieser woche mehrere millionen klicks
gemacht hat und schauen sie was dort
mittlerweile längst im umlauf ist damit
müssen wir uns auseinandersetzen
übrigens rechnet die bundesagentur für
arbeit bis ende des jahres mit
746.000 ukrainern in hartz4 da ist man
schnell mal bei über 1000 euro jeden
monat und das ist der eigentliche
skandal
bei müttern in rente die drei kinder zur
welt gebracht haben sind es sogar nur 7
151 euro ich finde dass es einfach nur
noch irre das ist nichts anderes als ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen für
ukraine das amt zahlt alles davon
könnten die steuerzahler in deutschland
nur träumen
dass das jetzt stimmen mit denen wir uns
auch außen schlimm genug dass ihr diesen
mist sogar noch ein spiel weil es ist
wirklich eigentlich 14 ja und es ist ein
aus gegeneinander ausspielen von
menschen die hilfe und unterstützung
brauchen die kinderreiche familie
braucht genauso hilfe und unterstützung
wie die die gerade aus einem krieg
gebiet kommen und sowas spielt man nicht
gegeneinander aus und um das jetzt auch
noch komplett zu machen am meisten
ärgert mich dass wir nicht auch mal
darüber reden dass jetzt schon wäre
dieser kriegstage menschen verhungern
sie haben es angesprochen weil
lieferungen nicht ankommen weizen die
frau nicht ankommen es gibt jetzt
schlimmste hungerkatastrophe auf der
welt die überhaupt nicht im blick sind
weil wir auch nachvollziehbar uns
natürlich auch mit dem geschehenen
stetter russische steht in diesem brief
habe diese aber das muss man mal
einordnen und die habe die stadt zu
leben doch von krisen das super in der
heißen sauna klasse jetzt kommen
menschen flucht super jetzt hungern die
ist ja auch egal wenn die hungern und
die leben immer nur von dem krisen
dieser welt und das ist ekelhaft und
widerlich und
wirklich einen solchen mit verlaub
solche aussage ich auch noch zu pflanzen
brasilianers links passiert ist weil das
längst überall im netz ist wahnsinnig da
kein gehör möchte ich dass sie sich
damit auseinandersetzen und argumente
haben weil das ist ihre aufgabe ist das
macht ja gott sei dank mit 85 prozent
der bundestag ist ja ganz ganz klar war
was hast du denn was ich der afg
entgegen entfallen das ist ekelhaft ist
menschen gegeneinander auszuspielen und
dass wir die verdammte pflicht haben
menschen zu helfen die auf der flucht
sind übrigens ist das sehr interessant
schauen sie sich mal an mit denen der
fds da gibt es leute wie frau von storch
die durchaus weiß aus ihrer
familiengeschichte was flucht und
vertreibung bedeutet dann wäre ich ja
mal ein bisschen demütig da gibt es eine
menge menschen die das selber erlebt
haben und wissen wie wichtig es ist dass
andere füreinander da sind und ich
schäme mich wirklich dass es solche dass
es solche aussagen gibt weil ganz ganz
ganz tausende millionen von deutschen
helfen den ukrainerinnen um seine und
machen das wirklich bravourös und dass
das muss herausgestellt werden